he played stew in the movie series
scream we've known him for many many
years eve my kid knows him as shaggy and
the scooby-doo franchise and we saw him
all throughout the Olympics coverage my
gosh as NBC was promoting tonight's
series premiere of good girls starring
Christina Hendricks in this man Matthew
Lillard good to see you sir yeah thanks
man you got it yeah I mean what's it
like to be seeing yourself every two
seconds I thought it was you and Shawn
white and then it was you and the
curling team and there was it's nonstop
unfortunately all the guys I was getting
run over every single promotion that's
like it is a show about women in this
moment of women in the world yes and I
was the guy getting run over hashtag you
good time for the show I'll say that I
mean and it's it premieres tonight and
I'm a big fan of Christina Hendricks
feasel obviously Mad Men which is on
here on audience all the time I'm so so
talented real and Mae Whitman I mean all
three of those women are incredibly
incredibly gifted so which is what's
your favorite sport if you had to choose
one I like this question so probably
English Premier League right now and I
like I mean I love anything which is
your club then man you okay someone man
you fan it's the only sport that I can
wake up with my kid on a Saturday
morning at like 7:00 a.m. and he'll
still snuggle and sit and watch the
house I will drink at 9:00 okay and he's
a big soccer player his name's Liam okay
but you know football he'll watch for a
second and he's playing flag football so
he's a little more into it now right but
soccer he'll sit and we'll watch that
game top to bottom now do you play it
yourself I do I actually I do play I am
you know I play an immense over 30
League which is completely embarrassing
to say okay cuz you know obviously I you
know we do we do as much research on all
guests as possible you know I know how
old you are over 30 are you the are you
the oldest I've got five good fouls I'm
gonna lay them out on that pitch I am I
am
really a team spirit guy okay I kind of
like the mascot
okay she's a nun I run for a solid four
minutes and then I tag myself out then
you tap out most guys won't come out but
I'm like me get me but I had a game
yesterday and I had an assist and assist
has a co-ed League all right so with D
division so walk me through the assisted
you bend it in there well you know
that's funny I got in the middle of the
pitch the ball pitch and I was I was
touch touch touch touch touch and we
have a woman on our team who is like you
know 20 okay she can still run after so
the men are yes I have two leagues I'm a
- I'm a TV guy Wow
this is my colleague which I never would
have had this much time in the men's
league okay okay I immediately change I
disagree up the pitch and she's making a
run and I pass it to the other side of
the guy she's running this way past the
other side the guy she one touches it in
the goal it was beautiful way to pass
I'm back tomorrow I'm gonna keep playing
guys no one can ever take that assist
away from you I want you know yeah I am
in so much pain right now so it's my in
strings and like that I can't move boy
you have to stretch man I I don't it's
funny when I first started when I first
started doing you know this job back in
the 90s I was a 26 27 year old guy buck
Martinez was my was doing a lot of games
with me you remember buck Martinez he
was a long time catcher in this league
right right he still blue jay and he
would do all this stretching when we
were working out like for 20-30 minutes
and I thought to myself and like dude
this is your workout and he gave me this
look sweetest man on the planet buck
Martinez gave me this look of like you a
hole yeah sure you know look how old you
are
goes one day you're gonna have to do
this that day is arrived yeah and now
I'm in so much pain like my hamstrings
are misra would you like to finish this
interview while stretching
for the television viewing audience so
much let's talk about your career
Matthew loader here well it's really
powerful I'm a really powerful actor
right real beautiful career well scream
I mean that that is a good one that was
a lot of bad ones but that was a good
one okay when was the last time anybody
said let's all get to get the gang back
together for another screen um I was the
last time you got a call if I am on if I
go to Twitter right now somebody's
talking about that in this moment in
this very moment yeah that's a big you
know people still love that that see I
mean they love that series of movies
mm-hmm
it's complicated Wes Craven god bless
his soul yes was sort of the guy that
was pushing that forward and I don't
know if any of us the old-school people
really have a desire to go back so and I
died in the first one you're all screams
oh it's not like you died what I died
I'm dead I never like oh yeah like
that'll stop a movie from being well
exactly
come on but I haven't made one yet okay
I liked it by the I bring it back I'm
available okay I'm available
no you're by me I don't know your your
shoot your shooting good girls right
little big show I'm not a big show at
10:00 Eastern Time right after the voice
and now but so you play the role IQ
could I could hear shaggy in you I can
hear that that no you got a little more
masculine enhance now hold on a second
well first of all I had no idea that
Shaggy's real name was Norville yeah
okay I had no idea but that's the Casey
Kasem character from back in our days
sir you never met him did you ever meet
him I did he'd play my dad um so what
happened is Casey did the voice for
years right and at some point he was
unable to sort of continue right and so
he passed the torch to me so I've done
the voice of shaggy like the last like
12 years which you know as an actor as
your life kind of ebbs and flows you're
not working you're working all right to
have a job like I have a day job that I
go to twice a week and I still record
the voice I got to tell you something
it's got it's truly I finally finally
after knocking on the door for years
here I got to do a roll and puppy-dog
pals on Disney forget it's coming out
here yeah well some of the most fun I've
ever had it's a blast
using a big cast record sort of all
these guest stars come in that are
incredibly talented right it's dude it's
a it is a gift that keeps on get it's
great yeah would you mind reading part
of the NFL cash rule as shaggy would you
mind doing it here we go
Matthew Lillard reading part of the NFL
catch rule as Shane as shaggy here in
the Rich Eisen show how do you know I
can read what if I kiss hey cuz you're
from the great state of Michigan control
the ball after a and B have been
fulfilled
okay rule number one yes secures control
of the ball in his hands or arms prior
to the ball touching the ground series
premiere of good girls tonight you play
the role of Dean bowling with Christina
Hendricks as as your wife yeah it's
great it's a great show yeah I mean
that's a good thing you're on a show
that's good I've been a lot of shows
that are bad well congratulations on
that but come back anytime sir good to
see Matthew lo at Matthew Lillard on
Twitter where they're talking about
another edition of scream right now the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience